so I want to start with uh I just want
to give you a thank you I really
appreciate your contributions to cinema
and I'm really glad that you spend your
time uh making movies I just really want
to start with that
um and I have a hopefully some unique
questions that you've not been asked
today
um if someone has actually never seen
any of your work before what is the
first thing you'd like them watching and
why I will say this film Bardo
I think is something that in a way I
feel
I feel contains a lot of the things that
that I have learned
and that I have I have accumulate some
experience that I'm I'm very happy about
this film you know you obviously have
many people that want to work with you
however maybe there's a project you
haven't been able to get made so if you
could get the financing to make anything
you want what would you make and why
I don't have nothing in mind I had a
project that I was developing a little
earlier but there was something that it
was suddenly I was attract much more by
this one that was personal and it got
much more power you know Traction in me
and and there was for a reason so I
think besides that project that I was
developing that I I was excited about it
um but in in the moment that it was
deviated and I started feeling more
toward this when I knew that it was not
enough traction and that's it so I don't
have nothing that I will say I will die
now to do it no I think it will come
hopefully probably but nothing that I
have in my pocket which of your previous
films and it might be this one uh
changed the most in the editing room in
ways that you did not expect
I will say a combination between uh
[Music]
foreign
I think those were the films that in a
way I could
I really went into an
there was a lot of Jamba lava you know
and uh they were changing depending on
how I put the pieces
so they were a little bit more liquid
and more flexible in that sense of
I think those were the the films that
were a little bit more edited
unchangeable in a way which of your
films actually ended up with the most
deleted scenes that are just still
sitting in a vault somewhere
I think this one
really yeah
there's many there's many scenes that I
love
that I shot and that didn't make it
because even in the even the original
version didn't make it
um
uh but I I really love it I I even
considering maybe to put it to bring
them at some point because there are
some of them that are really worth it
you know they were in the film but to do
something with them well I actually
wanted that's something that I'm so
curious about I've asked this of so many
filmmakers one of the advantages of
Netflix and streaming is you're not
beholden to a certain rule book The
there there's so many abilities to
release things as extras and obviously
your work is very I want to see it I
want to see what you've cut out I want
to see those scenes so would you
consider releasing these as deleted
scenes or would you consider doing an
Extended Cut or does any of that
interest you I don't know yet I don't
know yet how to do it because I think
you have to give it the context and and
some purpose you know what I mean I
think is not nothing that can leave you
like slices and that's it but I'm
interested because there's a a couple of
things uh you know some things that I
think is worth automatically and
substantially and Visually that were
very interesting thing that I I will
need to think how to really present it
and to give a proper context to that you
know but uh but yeah I would love to you
know to find that reason in Bardo in
many of your other films you have some
incredible shots things that my jaw just
hits the ground and I'm curious of of
your resume which shot or sequence ended
up being the real backbreaker the one
that you're like F this
mm-hmm
um I will say that one of the most
exciting moments it was in Revenant when
when we were shooting the battle and the
the the the the the Trappers are going
to toward the boat
and it was a huge huge camera movement
with a huge Crane and choreography and
special effects and water cold and uh
you know camera moves with the blocking
of every actor and hundreds of extras
and horses and fire and it was kind of
crazy so after you know several days of
rehearsaling and and finding out the way
to solve it and approach it properly
narratively dramatically with the
tension and with the Rhythm that it
needed and find the technical way to do
it
um
we were just going in through the end of
the day and we have such a little amount
of light and the things were not working
because something happened all the time
and the camera has to start running with
some guys panning to the left horses
coming this way then the camera applying
to the left there's a you know swords
and that and rifles and then completely
180 degrees then going there then going
to the water they're taking out from the
water then keep working with the water
and then they climb into the boat and
then you know pan and then we see the I
mean it was a crazy ambitious kind of
thing but after things it was just the
last take that literally there was no
exposition
and then we got it one and it was
I could I can't remember the the
excitement of the whole crew and the
whole actor that was like a huge
celebration this that's that that that's
one of the moments that I remembered I
was like okay I like this I like the
challenge to to solve things like that
you know and and it was very powerful
emotional there was a reason not only
like the technique but it was it was
really adrenaline uh uh going and you
know going on and that's what I want to
show you when you present to your crew
because some of your shots are even in
Bardo you have that amazing sequence in
the California dancing club I believe
it's called where it's a seven minute
shot that I as I was watching it my jaw
was on the ground because of how many
extras were in there and everything all
the choreography when you present to
your crew what you're planning on
accomplishing in a moment like that does
anyone start crying
no but they should because it was very
difficult that one because the challenge
was that this place was with no AC
in the middle of the pandemic
everybody's sweating smoking the extras
has the mask every day they have to take
out the mass some take some of them
obviously forgot to take out the mass so
that we have to cut and everybody
coughing we we thought that we will die
you know it was a you know the amount of
test for 800 people every day dress them
and then make sure that none of them
look to the camera and the choreography
and then to solve the camera thanks and
then obviously the timing of Ximena
clapping for the music was you know I I
edited before I wrote it from the script
so it the music was absolutely alive so
we have to hit the marks in every single
level so it took us yeah a couple of
days of really hard rehearsal and find
their the Rhythm I think every art
should aspire to music you know I think
music is God and Rhythm so in a way I
think I enjoyed that very much but it
was painful to do it you know I want to
ask you a specific question I love the
use of Let's Dance by David Bowie but
not just Let's Dance by David Bowie the
acapella version where you just hear his
voice and it's it's just a tremendous
sequence can you talk about why you
wanted that version of Let's Dance and
having David Bowie's voice really carry
that
I I wanted you know this is a moment of
sequence of Joy with family with friends
with Mexican you know salsa and Cumbia
and and you know the celebration of the
Narco speech and the you know all that
thing that make Mexico Mexican I want
this to be a very very sweaty electric
Vibe of my country and the enjoyment of
all these characters for a moment and at
some point I thought that oily would be
beautiful that this is obviously this is
a walk in the conscious of a character
all the film is that it's a lucid dream
and I want suddenly that this as in the
dreams always something is off something
feels real but there's something and I
want to get into that lucid dream again
liquid kind of sensation to get inside
him and how he was feeling about it and
to isolate him but still be surrounded
by like a shared loneliness but enjoying
the depth you know so I use that three
times I use it here I use it with Peter
Gabriel and Genesis song in the top shot
of the bed and I use it with Jose Jose
in the beach too so I think was a way
for me to understand that this guy can
talk without moving his lips
or can be you know mumbling songs inside
him without nobody noticing it it was a
way to be inside himself in my point of
view I really enjoyed the opening shot
of the film and I'm always curious how a
director a writer director picks how he
wants a film to open so how did you
decide on
um what's sort of behind you
um as the opening it was the first image
that came to my mind to be honest
because I mean it was something that I
recurrently dream
and it's a dream that is pleasant but at
the same time he's always feeling
dangerous because I always feel that I'm
flying very close to the ground and that
any false movement can really hit the
ground so it's like walking in the line
with some pleasure and feeling and it's
recurrent kind of thing sometimes
disappear for years and then it's only
come and it's every day or every week
that I feel the same and I have found
people that that have the same I don't
know if you have dreamed about that but
it's something and then I knew that that
was
and then I said okay it's going to be
the shadow project and I was very
excited about it
and then when I said okay how we gonna
do this
then it took me almost a year to solve
it how to do that because it's something
that I didn't know how to do it how to
solve it technically one the problem
with this film is that all the fabric of
this film is made of elusive kind of
emotions and feelings and dreams and
things but those things are immaterial
there's no recipe
and and to turn them in an idea and then
to write them and convert the sequence
and give a reason and then execute and
then flesh them out is super difficult
so anyway it's funny because now you see
how it's a shadowfly but to make that
was a real kind of equation how to
technically we can do that you know
anyway it was fascinating but it came to
me very early in the in the script one
of the things about this film because
it's a lucid dream and it's a it's all
these different moments sketched
together is that there is no actual net
well let me let me take that back I'm
curious about the editing process
because that's ultimately the final
rewrite and it's where this entire every
film comes together can you sort of talk
about how the film possibly changed the
structure as you were in the editing
room because there are many ways of
playing this funny enough end up very
very faithful not perfectly but faithful
to the original script or something to
the idea of the script it came it was
built in 32 sequences so in a way every
sequence in a way it's Blended
again with the other one with no story
with no story right and and there's no
structure it's only an atmosphere
and the only kind of a spine is or a
middle or Center is is emotional so so I
I was the film is actually a flexible
film in that sense
but I founded that in the script it took
me four years to put that together so it
was not so different from the script I I
extract some things that as I told you
didn't make it
uh but they were in a way attending the
chronological order that they were
intended you know can I ask you how many
deleted scenes did you end up with we're
talking like 30 minutes or more yeah
yeah like 30 minutes probably yeah now
that I've seen the entire film the
ending I don't want to get into spoilers
but the ending opens the door on
watching the film again and presenting
you with new information that allows you
to see things and I'm curious if you
ever thought about presenting some of
the information at the end earlier in
the film to change your perspective on
what you were watching or was it always
designed with that in mind
no it was always design in mind you know
what you said I think is if there's any
structure of this film is circular you
know it basically ends when it starts
there's a famous novel in in in in in in
of uh Julio cortazar and a genius
Argentinian uh uh uh writer that is
called rayuela and rail is very famous
because it's a novel that actually you
can start in the middle in the beginning
in the end and no matter where you going
it's a circular thing and you will
understand everything so you know I
think that this film is a little bit
like rayuela you know it's made in
circles there's no like literally like a
act one act two act three plot point no
that doesn't exist it's just a dream and
it you can go in in the moment that you
want and and if you put together the
beginning and the end it will start
again
I'm curious who do you trust for honest
feedback and when you showed them this
film was any feedback that you got
um like give it like Did you sort of all
of a sudden say oh that makes a lot of
sense I need to I need to adjust this
yeah I think normally I show the film to
close friends that I respect that I have
you know that I trust that I have
confidence
and uh obviously the two that you know
is uh is Guillermo del Toro and Alfonso
Corona
and uh and I think uh yeah it was it's
great to have that you know what I mean
I think there's point of view that
sometimes we do not agree
but sometimes they can open their
interesting exercise for me to apply and
that's always super beneficial you know
we do that from the beginning of our
careers you know so yeah I think they
were they were very supportive and I
have another friends that I I was very
very very happy that they kind of give
me their thoughts you know I loved
seeing the movie last night in IMAX and
your choice of the large format 65 mil
for you know how you shot it can you
sort of talk about why you wanted to
shoot it on that format because
especially because of that you know I
think this film because the canvas and
the paintings that I wanted being this a
dream and big events and intimate events
but I think I want this to feel
cinematic sensorial immersive to get
into the dream of some person you know
in virtual reality carne Arena I put the
people in that and I'm I don't know I
was very interested in this sensorial
immersive situation that you can really
enjoy Cinema with a big format with the
sound design that took us one year to
read really Embrace people in this kind
of you know
trip in this trip and I think the big
format is is made for that and we're
going to have a 70 millimeters in in LA
and New York we're going to have a 35
print too but I think the 70 millimeter
I'm gonna revise it now in one hour I'm
going to photochem to revise it so we
are finishing so yeah I love the I love
the big format you know when you say
revise it you mean like watch it for
color correction and stuff exactly
exactly yeah
um so uh
so New York and La I'm just trying to
think about seeing it in 70 millimeter
now uh yeah yeah I I think you will
enjoy it if we hit the right spot it has
been challenged the 35 looks amazing
this is pristine and powerful and the 70
I think if we hit the right
um thing I think it will be beautiful
too well the thing that I've also found
is that um when someone shoots in 65 mil
65 the way you did and then it gets
shrunk down to 35. it still looks
incredible it looks amazing actually
because of the way you shot it
originally exactly yeah that's exactly
right the information that is now in
these cameras is just crazy you know and
that leads me to my next thing I'm
almost out of time but how shooting was
65 like this I love the IMAX format is
shooting an IMAX or this kind of format
something that you want to do in the
future for your you know up whatever you
choose to do next is that something that
you you know you fell in love with that
format yeah I think 65 for me but you
know sometimes you have you have you you
I think the pending the film I think
every film needs and demand its own
grammatical language under its own
texture and its own thing you know I I
you you can see kind of things in 16
millimeters with all lenses and glasses
you know and and it's super powerful and
beautiful and and it's a little hazy and
you know the uh uh what I'm saying is
not everything has to be crispy and
crisp pristine I think that every film
demands so I think it depends in the
film that I think I choose what is the
right
patina you know for each of them you
know you obviously plan your shots and
what you want to accomplish before you
get on set very clearly
um and I'm curious how much ends up
being spontaneous on set when you are in
the moment and how much is it sort of
very regimented based on what you've
previously planned I think in this film
everything was absolutely pre-planned
rehearse control and Incredibly specific
every step every movement camera actors
uh it was I did storyboards for each of
them so it was I think it's the much
more is the more precise film I have
done in my life and the reason is that
when you are trying to get that lucid
dream sensation where something is off
and that you you that you you are
grounded in reality but that that the
whole thing had you cannot capture that
you cannot improvise that that you don't
achieve that by chance you have to
design it in every sense with with with
the design of the light Direction the
camera movement the performance of the
actor has to be not reacting but
observing all the time the the the the
the lights are moving even when nobody
perceive it so I did a lot of things for
you to feel something is off
and and that has to be perfectly planned
and design because if not it will be too
real or too you know so all the film
navigating this you know
reality imagination all the time so you
have to design that to have to go build
it you know on that note I need to stop
I'm just going to say again thank you
for making movies I really appreciate
your art
um and people have have fun at photochem
thank you very much thank you for your
time good to see you